no Jesus hi guys it's fried Ariane its
grace I haven't done a fried Aryan so so
long but this week Warren says a lot of
things have been happening this week
things like hello
I have misplaced my other handheld
pocket camera so Friday is gonna be on
my cell phone
take that whoever is offended by that
look at my hair wet actually don't click
off this video from that alone get out
of here while you can
right now we're in the car where I have
a full day today it's Monday and we are
headed to a pre-production meeting for
something that is very cool and yet
again something I cannot tell you about
because it's something don't you hate it
when you get like reprimanded by your
parents you know why and they're like
because I said so
yeah that's one of these moments why can
I tell you about it
and also I didn't say so some higher-up
people said so don't the next exit on
the right don't tell me how to get to
where I need to get to except please
don't stop telling me because I have no
idea and then this happened
this is behind the scenes of our
nofilter hangout like you guys are all
there if you guys are here now you guys
are all in Frank diary yeah that's all
FRA diary you and me both we're at the
fries soon what about this shenanigan no
context Oh what the years of spoofing a
goof it's a video on a secret project
more secret I know I'm sick of this
[ __ ] already mm-hmm I'm not this
one's fine it's really good I'm very
proud of you
sir fort bye sick and whoa
ouchy wow cheese what about this time
but by now I think you guys all know the
ones one of the secret projects that
I've been working on that actually I'm
currently working on this week in fact I
didn't realize that the news is gonna
come out I would have told you I just
didn't know if I was allowed to do or
not
and now it's out there I am working on a
pilot for II I'm really excited about
it's really fun and I like the show and
I think I would watch it if I wasn't me
in the show I don't think I know I would
watch it so I hope that it works out
that's the thing about a pilot is that
they have to then decide if they want
your show to be a full show or if they
want you to have done all of that work
for nothing
Hollywood Taco Tuesday thank God
I've been looking for
a weekend in person
DJ Tanner whoo yes whoo
look just be enough
and then look at this dynamic team right
now yeah I you post perfectly you know
that it's 11 something hi hi and we're
setting up for the second-to-last shot I
think I can show you this I'm gonna do
it anyway look at all this look at these
guys
yeah can't hold them down the two party
animals hanging out in an empty all a
just Club pretty neat and look what's
out here
other than I mean there's a lot of stuff
going on in here which is really great
but look what's happening out here
that's happening he's here hi I'm great
by the way I'd never introduced myself
let's shake like this Daniel nice to
meet you he's gonna be playing you're
playing a security guard right yeah
you're playing really well cuz I really
thought you were part of a birthday the
annex here yeah let's go Wednesday here
we go okay you tell me when Josh is -
josh is gonna put a microphone on me
just you look beautiful with this like
light that's coming through right here
okay let's get ready for this well there
you go there was my weekend recap I hope
that that was inspiring for you so that
you make some kind of groundbreaking art
that influences the world and changes
perspective if not and
see Camarillo